Cheyenne's in Arkansas hey Cheyenne how
are you I'm doing good how are y'all
better than we deserve how can we help
well I just need some advice from you
I just really trust your wisdom so I've
been [ __ ] debt-free since March and
then about a month ago I left a domestic
violent relationship with my ex-husband
first in February and I'm also pregnant
I'm expecting my baby in May and I just
moved back home to Arkansas from
Minnesota so everything is just like
whoo-hoo Roland
um I'm living with my mom and my sister
my siblings and high school friends are
nearby and I'm just kind of curious of
what to do because my mom so I've been
trying to help my mom for at least a
year get out of debt so she's at least
60 or 80 grand in debt besides her
mortgage I don't think you're and you're
the one in a mess let's get you straight
first before you start fixing other
people I mean you Cubans you've been
through hell and you're broke right yeah
yeah how long were you married to this
twerp about a year I'm sure glad you got
yeah I didn't even realize it I mean
it's kind of crazy I left went back went
back it's coming nuts
how everything's so into place are you
doing the pregnancy really oh yeah I
mean once I got pregnant the fog lifted
and I was like yo why am i putting up
with you but I mean I guess I'm just
curious because like I'm just curious
what you think about so did you show me
the divorce is final yes it was
finalized in February it wasn't messy
okay I'm sorry but you just left so you
went back to him after the divorce yeah
I know but now I'm
I mean I'm done for good because you
know like I said there was really a fog
and I didn't I knew there was something
wrong but I didn't realize that for you
it was just gonna keep changing we'd
tried therapy so many times so talk
about your money do you have a job no
I've been putting I have an interview
Friday been putting in resume left and
right and I I wasn't our therapist in
Minnesota but I don't have licensing
here so I'm what does it take to get
licensed there what oh honey I have to
have to take some extra courses and then
pay $200 for a test that I've already
taken once and failed I'm not sure if
I'm ready I only have 800 dollars to my
name and I can start working doing other
things there's a live-in position about
an hour away from my family
and it would bring in around fourteen
hundred a month and I don't have any
debt so my bills are just the basic
stuff like phone and insurance for my
car so I'm trying to kind of decide if I
should you know move out as soon as I
get some income or if I should stay with
my family and save and save and save for
the baby because he doesn't intend on
taking care of it financially okay and
given given the domestic violence order
protection so I'm just like yeah we want
to thank you anyway as far away from all
this as possible yeah I don't know if I
should die on you man how can you make
the most money and take care of you in
the baby
probably I don't know I guess I guess
get licensed exactly exactly that's how
you can make the most money and take
care of you and the baby and if they'll
give you a place if they'll give you a
place to live while you work five jobs
getting the money together and getting
that test passed and getting the classes
taken or whatever you got to do in order
to get that certification in Arkansas
and get it done and also call the state
or the light the area that does the
licensing
and explain to them what you've got and
what you're doing and is there any way
they can help you speed this up okay and
and and I should move out of my family's
home for the sake of you know myself if
you need to I didn't hear an issue with
your family at the moment but if there's
an issue with your family that's fine
but you you're not able to take care of
other people you have a full-time job
just getting back on your feet after
this mess you've been through I'm so
sorry
how you call me anytime and I'll help
you any way I can't get out